welcome back to cbs this morning
with father's day coming up this weekend
there is a renewed push in washington
to give new parents maybe the best
present of all
more time to bond with their babies
but here's the thing paid time off for
dads in particular
is available at just nine percent of
companies in this country
and even when dads can take time off
many don't feel
they should and most take two weeks or
less
we spoke with texas democrat colin
allred he's a former nfl linebacker
turned u.s congressman
who has now twice taken time off to be a
dad
in dallas as both of us cared for our
newborns at home
he explained to me how he's hoping to
extend the very same opportunity
to everyone this is a whole new meaning
to
politicians kissing babies as parents
like colin allred will tell you
babies are a full-time job oh
a little split up a little spit up which
is why in 2019
allred took two weeks off from
washington to be home with his newborn
son
jordan and believe it or not it was the
first paternity leave
ever announced by a member of congress
it was really important to me i mean i
i grew up without a father my whole life
i thought
when i have a chance to be a father i'm
going to be a good dad and i'm going to
be there
and you know i think in our in our
household my wife and i try to keep
things as equal as possible
and this was part of that
earlier this year when allred's wife ali
gave birth to their second child cameron
he took another leave
this time for a month what gave you the
confidence to
go a little further two weeks wasn't
long enough
with the first one for my wife for for
me
for our son jordan i really felt like
i needed longer the truth is most ads
get less time than
that despite research showing that
paternity leave is tied to improved
health and development in children
and by fostering equality can actually
increase employment
and pay for mothers men even when they
have the chance to take paternity leave
they do not always take it what's your
theory behind it what's going on there
yeah i mean there's an expectation in
the workplace
uh that you know you didn't have the
baby so
what do you need the time off for right
um
and there's also of course kind of the
cultural expectation
in many cases that the mom is going to
you know do all of the child care and of
course what we've seen
he's going to sleep well you've seen
well done what's that
you hear that that was pretty good it's
a veteran women are being asked to do
all the child care
all the housework and still be in the
workforce
and you know that's just not working the
united states is as you've probably
heard before
one of just two countries along with
papua new guinea that does not guarantee
paid parental leave to anyone and they
need to strengthen paid leave
let's support working families by
supporting paid family leave
paid leave makes a real difference in
ordinary people's lives
i can't think of another issue that both
former president obama
and president trump and now joe biden
all have mentioned in major speeches
including the state of the union
and yet it doesn't get done yeah
you know that's one of the things i
think makes people so frustrated with
washington in general
is that you can have a lot of agreement
around something but still
it's very difficult to get anything done
and to get it through and
to become law president biden has
proposed giving workers 12 weeks of paid
leave under his american family's plan
but that would cost about 225 billion
dollars
and while democrats want to raise taxes
on the wealthy in order to pay for it
republicans do not whether or not it can
be bipartisan i don't know
you know yeah i know that we're gonna
get it done
either way that was both ends he doesn't
like reconciliation he's not a fan
yeah we got a diaper that's got to be
changed here
that was the cutest thing i've ever seen
yeah so amazing it was uh
it was difficult to maintain a train of
thought while caring for our newborns uh
i think baby cameron's reaction there at
the end is a stand-in for much of the
country where it's like look
bipartisan support for this like let's
get it done figure out a way to pay it
is miraculous as you point out given the
fact that
both sides that you know are speaking
out about it and
in favor of it that they can't get this
done yeah well at the beginning of the
piece you said he was the first man to
take
rental leave and it was in 2019 i had to
double check the script because i was
like that cannot be
no it's true and there's no official
leave for anyone in congress and people
have presumed to have snuck in some days
here and there but it's a big deal for a
man
a father to come forward and say i'm
doing this it's important it's for my
family
and actually i've noticed since my
oldest son who's going to be 12 this
summer was born to now with eloise
the pressure has shifted it's not go
back to work it's why aren't you
home and on that point i will be taking
additional leave in july there you go
join me while you have now is that the
first interview where you ever used a
baby bottle to uh
to gesture yes to make it i thought it
was very effective i'm going to keep it
on the workbook that was very powerful
all right that was great tony